et puis cette question les amendes et
les peines de prison qu'un citoyen
français risques et s'ils ne
respectaient pas les règles du
confinement sont elles légales certains
estiment que ce délit créé est contraire
à la constitution
le conseil constitutionnel doit trancher
justement pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec carbon de saisir et avocats
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pour qu'on comprenne
bien le conseil constitutionnel beau
dire si oui ou non
sanctionner quelqu'un lorsqu'ils ne
respectait pas les règles du confinement
est contraire à la constitution ou pas
c'est exactement ça la question qui lui
est posée c'est de savoir si quelqu'un
qui a été verbalisé trois fois et plus
par des contraventions mérite
automatiquement d'être puni en plus pour
pour avoir commis le délit d'avoir
répété trois fois la même infraction
alors vous êtes spécialiste du droit je
vous pose la question selon vous est-ce
que c'est constitutionnel
non je pense que la question qui a été
posée au conseil constitutionnel est une
excellente question pourquoi parce que
nous obéissons en france à un principe
qui n'est pas compliqué à comprendre
c'est celui du de la légalité des délits
et des peines
oh lala règles initiales étaient très
imprécise rappelez vous c'était celle
des achats de première nécessité d'un
déplacement impérieux pour motif
familial c'est à dire des choses qui
sont imprécises qui tiennent à chacun
qui sont d'une appréciation qui peut
varier d'un individu à l'autre
et quelle est la conséquence de cette
imprécision c'est que vous pouviez être
verbalisés selon le fait que la police
ou la gendarmerie qui vous contrôler
vérifier elle-même la pertinence du
motif qui vous conduisait à vous
déplacer
et c'est cet arbitraire là qui ne permet
pas de dépasser le simple stade de la
contravention
c'est à dire que on en reste à la
contravention on voit bien l'objectif du
législateur qui est de dire si vous
enfreignez les règles plus trois fois
c'est que vous n'avez
a compris qu'il y avait un impératif
sanitaire qui présidait à tous mais
l'extrême problème de la même question
c'est de savoir si on reste dans un
cadre juridique ou non et par conséquent
le simple fait que vous soyez verbalisée
par la police ne suffit pas à établir
que vous avez commis un délit
pourquoi parce qu'une contravention ça
ne permet pas par exemple de savoir si
matériellement les faits qui sont
relevés par la police ou la gendarmerie
sont tout à fait exact peut-être que
l'achat d'une bouteille de coca cola par
une jeune femme qui a été verbalisé
correspondait pour être vraiment une
première nécessité une contravention ça
ne lui permet pas de s'en expliquer une
contravention c'est un simple constat
qui n'a rien de contradictoire et par
conséquent dire que trois fois de suite
sur des constats qui ne sont pas établi
contradictoirement vous devenez un
délinquant
eh bien ça ne correspond pas pour
répondre à votre question
un accroc à la constitution française
alors ça voudrait dire qu'il ya une
faille en fait que le législateur a créé
quelque chose de contraire à la
constitution
comment est ce possible parce que les
législateurs sont allés trop vite il
faut dire un peu qu'ils ont dû agir dans
l'urgence
oui vous avez raison mais agir dans
l'urgence ça suppose quelquefois d'agir
trop vite et bien en l'espèce le texte
dans la façon dont il a été rédigé a été
rédigée trop rapidement sans bien
considéré les principes fondamentaux du
droit français
vous avez une simple équation
mathématique qui vous permet de bien
comprendre le texte dit que en réalité
si vous avez récidivé deux fois commis
trois fois un acte dans un délai de
trente jours vous devenez un délinquant
automatiquement
mais le délai de contestation d'un pv
d'une contravention est de 90 jours donc
ça veut dire que vous pouvez entrer en
voie de condamnation à l'égard de
quelqu'un qui n'aurait même pas pu
protester une de ces trois verbalisation
les deux ou les trois vous voyez ça
c'est la manifestation de ce que vous
venez d'indiquer une précipitation et
une précipitation qui n'est pas con
forme aux règles du droit applicable en
france
alors si les sages estiment que c'est
contraire à la constitution que va-t-il
se passer les gens condamnés vont voir
leur condamnation annulée
exactement madame exactement ça voudra
dire que le texte n'était pas applicable
c'est à dire qu'il n'était il était
dépourvu de légalité
il n'était pas conforme à la loi et par
conséquent les poursuites engagées sur
la base d'un texte des mois sur la base
d'un texte qui n'était pas conforme au
droit français et bien ne saurait être
l'objet d'une condamnation en droit
français
carbon le cese vous êtes avocat merci
pour votre éclairage et merci d'avoir
été en direct sur rt france